four guys at least boosting testosterone
is one of the best ways to get a full
mind and body upgrade it's not just
about building more muscle and burning
more fat it's also about improving your
sleep about strengthening your bones
about getting more Drive more
determination improving your mood and
getting that masculine aura that many of
us associate with being an alpha male so
for all these reasons looking for ways
to increase your testosterone is a
worthy cause and in this video I'm going
to look at whether you can do that
safely and to a worthwhile degree
without breaking the bank I'm gonna look
first at the supplements and the other
chemical means by which you can increase
testosterone looking at whether any of
them are worth it in terms of the risk
and then I'm going to go on to look at
the lifestyle factors and other methods
you can use to increase your tea levels
so stay tuned and let's do that shall we
some say the main way to raise
testosterone one that most people know
is by using steroids and steroids a
little bit controversial though heard it
here first guys steroids controversial
probably easiest if we talk about how
they work first steroids work in a
number of ways sometimes it involves
injecting pure testosterone into your
blood in various different forms
sometimes it involves injecting or
consuming DHT or a derivative of DHT DHT
here's the hydro testosterone which is a
similar kind of hormone to testosterone
it's actually more potent and has some
of the side-effects removed but
obviously still not perfect otherwise
we'd all be doing it and the third way
that a steroid can work is by binding to
the androgen receptors of the androgenic
steroids steroids that bind to the
antigen receptors mimic the way that
testosterone works and as far as your
body is concerned it has more
testosterone in it so this will increase
your muscle mass your recovery it'll
help you burn fat and just make you look
and perform much better and this is
obviously something that a lot of guys
are really very interested in doing
unfortunately though as I said it also
comes with a few side effects the first
side effect is that it can cause the
symptoms of high testosterone you raise
testosterone you're going to get acne
and if acne
you mean if you've got sensitive hair
follicles your hair can fall out so that
can be lead to male pattern baldness
it can cause mood swings and SAAM near
that sort of thing that would be livable
will be so bad except it can also excess
testosterone can also convert into
Eastridge and and then this leads to
manboobs
gynecomastia it can lead to water
retention and yet more mood swings so
that's also bad most guys are a little
bit more put off by the prospect of
manboobs the steroids that work via
dehydrated testosterone do not cause
this problem but you know they have
their own risks another issue with
steroids a lot of them is that they will
suppress your endogenous production of
testosterone in other words when your
body registers that you've got high
testosterone like super high
testosterone it responds by producing
less
of its own and this of course means that
when you come off your cycle you have
very low testosterone levels and some
guys will try and manage this using a
post psychotherapy that's PCT but that
only works you know so well and
sometimes it won't work again there's
many people like watching this thinking
like Oh nonsense it works just fine but
it is a risk and it can happen and the
problem is that a lot of steroids a
liver toxic meaning they can hurt your
liver and they're more liver toxic if
you swallow them orally but injecting
has its own downsides because it causes
marks on your skin and also you've got
to inject yourself which I'm certainly
not going to do stars are also illegal
mostly they're certainly bound by most
athletic organizations and they're
expensive
and you have to buy them online off
people that you have no way of trusting
so in general for me personally steroids
not worth the risk obviously I can
understand the appeal being more
athletically awesome and something that
certainly I would be interested in but
to me the risks are just not worth it
so the question is what can we do that's
going to bring about similar benefits to
steroids but not involve using steroids
and the answer is nothing
the closest thing at the moment the
people are talking about is Psalms
they're selective androgen receptor
modulators so we talked about the
androgen receptors a minute ago sounds
work in a similar way they bind to the
androgen receptors or they modulate the
way they work think make them more
sensitive and this means that
testosterone has exerts its effect on
those sites because they're selective it
may only affect certain areas and the
idea is that sounds will only affect
your muscle and not the virility effects
so it won't cause the growth in hair
around your body or the deepness and
voice or the hair loss etc so that's the
theory and theoretically it sounds great
people say that sounds are you know safe
healthy and they bring all the positive
effects with none of the side effects
you know what they say if it sounds too
good to be true it probably is not true
and yeah results online from people
reporting on it are very mixed some
people say that it does suppress your
testosterone levels and you'll have to
do your own research on that a lot of
people say it's not as effective of
steroids and many people say it's not
effective at all it looks like you're
treating a lot of the same risks with
smaller benefits and yeah again it's
probably just not worth it and then the
big kicker is it sounds a very expensive
prohibitively / prohibitively say so
that will put a lot of people off
the next peg down from that is probably
pro hormones pro hormones are substances
you eat that get where you eat that you
take or whatever and they get converted
into testosterone or DHT so you consume
them and then your body uses them to
make the something with the same effect
as a steroid do they work well I
accidentally took a prohormone once
genuine accidentally because I was not
the smartest tool in the shed back then
I I thought it was a testosterone
booster but it was in fact a pro hormone
called oxalá I took it for a while I did
see actually an increase in size and
definition and yes I would say for me
personally it worked but the thing with
these sorts of things is that your
mileage will vary and as we get further
down this list you'll find that a lot so
yeah I took this and I found that I
increased my muscle mass a little bit
and cut a little bit but at the same
time I also had a mood swings more just
I was miserable so it definitely
affected my hormones in terms of my
emotions and again probably not worth it
they're also not safe either they can
still be liver toxic they can still
suppress your natural testosterone
levels and the effects are much lower
than test then steroids would be so
again you're having a lot of the same
risks but none of the same benefits or
very reduced benefits so with that in
mind again to me not worth it
so going even further back down the list
we now have testosterone boosters
testosterone boosters are supplements
products that work by using ingredients
that have been shown in studies normally
to somehow affect the testosterone
levels positively and this can again
include all manner of different things
so you have saponins which include the
likes of tribulus terrestris this is a
herb that's been shown to boost
testosterone levels I think via
cholesterol you have daa des Bach
d-aspartic acid and this works by
increasing the amount of luteinizing
hormone been shown in studies to be
effective and some studies not to be
effective and then you have things like
zma which is zinc magnesium and vitamin
b6 and basically all these things have
been shown in studies to slightly
increase your testosterone levels and so
the idea is you stick them all into one
big pot and call it alpha male
testosterone booster crazy max and then
you claim that it has effects similar to
steroids obviously it doesn't have
effects similar to steroids it has very
marginal effects a lot of people say
that these products don't work at all
and again mileage will vary depending on
who you are and who you ask because
we've all got different biology and I
think different things work differently
for different people but the point is
that in these studies in the best case
scenario you're looking at like a 30%
increase in testosterone now
testosterone is measured in ng DL which
is nano grams per deciliter or something
like that anyways
normal is like 252 up to a thousand
which would be really good if you had a
thousand mg / DL but if you take
steroids they can go up to several
thousands and some competitive
bodybuilders have got insane numbers
here and apparently one guy even had
twenty five thousand so if you are
someone who's got a fairly average
testosterone level about 500 and then
you take the aspartic acid and it works
perfectly just as it did in the studies
then you're raising it by 30% and 30% of
500 is 150 maybe so you've gone up to
650 mg/dl and that's not actually gonna
make that much of a difference
so it has worked perfectly but you
haven't got mass is more muscle mass and
you haven't you're not going to notice a
lot of weight loss and probably won't
even affect your mood that much so again
there is it worth it taking supplements
like this that's up to you I've actually
been testing the a a myself because I
find it's the one that has the most
compelling evidence some studies show it
raising testosterone by a a decent
degree other studies have failed to
replicate that as it's pretty much
always the case but what made me
interested in it was the fact that a lot
of people use daa when they're coming
off of a psalm cycle in order to get
their testosterone levels back up to
normal amounts so that's one sign to me
that it must at least be somewhat
effective for people who have low
testosterone and probably therefore a
little bit effective for those who have
normal testosterone so that's the other
thing to keep in mind as I said earlier
testosterone isn't just about building
muscle and burning fat and just because
you're not raising it to steroid levels
which is dangerous anyways that doesn't
mean that it's not worthwhile if you can
increase your testosterone levels just a
little bit you can consider it almost
like any other supplement just to
improve your health maybe a nootropic so
even if the results are subtle in theory
increasing testosterone should help you
heal from wound slightly better sleep
slightly better improve your mood drive
recovery and energy levels and to me all
that is worth at least a little bit of
money and experimentation I'll be sure
to let you know how my DAA experiments
go in a future video and also my
experimentations with other testosterone
boosters but overall for someone looking
to get massive changes in their body
composition a testosterone booster is
probably going to be money wasted
so instead let's have a look at dietary
and lifestyle changes that you can use
so in terms of a diet you can provide
your body with the precursors to create
testosterone naturally I said that ZMA
zinc magnesium and vitamin b6 was a
supplement you could use to increase
testosterone this is something you take
just before bed it helps you sleep
better and then during that rest you
have a anabolic surge of growth hormone
and testosterone that's the idea of
anyways so obviously you can get zinc
magnesium and vitamin b6 in your diet
and just doing that will be enough to
give you a slight increase in
testosterone and hopefully things like
this are going to add up make a big
difference the most important thing to
do though is to get more saturated fat
and the reason for this is that
saturated fat which is actually healthy
for us now we know looking at more
modern research can increase your
cholesterol levels the good cholesterol
the HDL high density lipoprotein type
and when you do that this increases
testosterone why because your body makes
it steroid hormones from cholesterol
that means that if you increase tests or
increase cholesterol you're literally
giving your body the raw materials to
make more testosterone from so many
people recommend eating something like
eggs just before bed or full fat milk
and doing this just before bed because
again sleep is when you produce the most
testosterone so by giving your body that
supply that'll be available as you're
resting in theory should increase your
testosterone levels I just want to
quickly mention that as we're talking
about using saturated fats one
alternative to using steroids this
reportedly quite effective actually is
called gomad that stands for a gallon of
milk a day and this is an extreme method
for hardgainers and people who have very
low testosterone very fast metabolisms
in order to build muscle bulk and size
and it obviously involves drinking a
gallon of milk a day in order to get
huge amounts of protein from it and
large amounts of saturated fats in order
to boost the testosterone and obviously
it's not terribly healthy too much of
anything isn't good for you and that
much milk can definitely cause issues so
especially this only for short amount of
time but if you're desperate and you
want something that's the closest thing
to illegal alternative to steroids I've
not tried it personally but heard
reports that the results are close
to a very mild sterile cycle in terms of
the growth and the increase in size but
of course this isn't something you can
sustain it's also pretty extreme and has
causes bloating in spots as that is the
best case scenario so don't recommend it
but just out of interest if you wanted
wanted to know what a way to boost your
anabolism was that's quite extreme but
not steroids that's it go mad in terms
of diet an increase in saturated fat is
probably the biggest improvement you can
make except also for one more and that
is to increase your intake of carbs and
not only to increase your intake of
carbs but to spread those carbs out
nicely throughout the day and the reason
for this is that your testosterone
levels are very closely linked with your
blood sugar levels when your blood sugar
levels dip your body responds by
producing Grayling the hunger hormone as
well as cortisol the stress hormone and
Maya statin the hormone that breaks down
muscle tissue so not good so basically
you go into a more of a fight-or-flight
response your body is saying I need
energy I need to look for food quickly
and thus you have this more catabolic
state where you're burning food where
you're burning to get the energy that
you need because you don't have it in
your blood and the way you're not
building muscle because that's not very
energy efficient at a point where you
don't have food but if you increase your
levels of blood sugar then you can also
decrease your levels of cortisol and
when you decrease the cortisol you
increase testosterone that's because
testosterone is anabolic and it's to do
with building muscle so it's when you're
in a calorie surplus when you have
plenty of energy that your body says
great now I can build me some muscle so
in other words if you're constantly
running long distances starving yourself
in a low-carb diet
nervous stressed then you're going to be
the kind of person who's very slim and
who struggles to bulk and put on mass on
the other hand if you're someone who's
chilled relaxed and eat a ton just like
the old classic bodybuilders in films
like pumping iron then you're going to
remain in an anabolic state for as long
as possible and you can be able to put
on lots of mass and that's just as
important as getting all of that
saturated fat plus lots of minerals in
your diet and that's probably going to
have a the biggest impact
testosterone levels more so than other
things like even tribulus terrestris if
you can just keep your blood sugar high
by eating plenty of carbs and eating
loads of protein to build the muscle and
eating lots of saturated fat to provide
yourself with the raw materials to make
the testosterone then you're gonna stay
in this anabolic state as SS sauce train
loads a muscle of course that does mean
you might also gain weight because
you're increasing your carbohydrates and
that's the reason the bodybuilders will
often go through a bulking phase and a
cutting phase and you know you can
balance this how you want whether you
think it's worth the risk of adding fat
to increase the testosterone that's up
to you but yeah that's the easiest way
to increase it even though it does come
with that slight downside
and so that brings us to the last piece
of our puzzle lifestyle and one thing
right off the bat that is incredibly
important for boosting your testosterone
in terms of lifestyle is getting lots of
sleep
like I've said multiple times already in
this video sleep is when you produce
testosterone apparently you produce the
maximum amount of testosterone at 4:00
a.m. in the morning a day how true that
is but either way the more sleep you get
the more testosterone you'll produce and
the same goes for growth hormone and all
the other anabolic goodness and this is
something I've noticed myself I can tell
they've got high testosterone or not
through a variety of means mainly
through My Morning Glory and the more I
sleep the more I am to wake up with
signs of high testosterone and when I'm
deprived of sleep
I just feel shattered and wasted and you
can feel the difference and you can test
this using a hand
dynamometer check out one of my previous
videos for more information on that so
what I always say to people is if you
want to build the maximum testosterone
and if you're just interested in bulking
you need to live like a lion that means
you need to eat big you need to train
hard and then use a sleep big and rest
big and that rest needs to continue
throughout the day and that means you
mustn't get too stressed you mustn't
exert yourself too much I mean literally
just as chill as possible and in fact
keeping your heart rate low even will
help me to build tip more testosterone
so in other words the more you can relax
after you've worked out the more you
build testosterone once again though of
course there are downsides to just
chilling all day it won't improve your
cardio that well and it's also not so
very practical so again you're gonna
have to decide whether that's worth it
or not for you then we have things like
exercise now a lot of people believe
that exercise will improve their
testosterone levels and they can do big
compound lifts like bench press and
deadlift in order to increase their
testosterone as much as possible however
studies more recently show that this
kind of testosterone the kind of
testosterone boosted by exercise doesn't
actually have a big impact on your
muscle synthesis synthesis and that
could be because it's too short to term
a spike you know having sex also boost
your testosterone but I don't think
that's going to make anybody suddenly
great more muscle or mighty because the
amounts are too small there's been
confirmed in two separate studies
obviously more research needs to be done
but if you think you're boosting your
fostering levels by a huge amount by
just squatting you might be a little bit
disappointed to find that the results
aren't exactly what you think they are
and another problem with compound
exercises when you're using that
argument is that the only reason that
compound exercises boost more
testosterone is because you're using
more muscles at once creating more
damage and thus releasing more
metabolites however if you do a full
body workout isolating each muscle group
you'll still cause the same amount of
muscle damage you're still using the
same number of muscles and you'll still
create the same amount of testosterone
so actually I haven't seen many other
people pick up on this yet but squatting
for testosterone might be a little bit
misguided sorry to break the news there
which isn't say shouldn't do it's got
loads of other great benefits other than
that but yes so that wouldn't make a big
difference and I'm also not entirely
sold on this whole idea of power
positions to boost your testosterone
I don't think standing in the mirror
like this in the bathroom is going to
increase your testosterone to a point
where you're feeling big changes in your
muscle mass however if you can reduce
stress like I said that will do it and I
think also boosting your confidence will
increase testosterone it's a kind of
two-way correlation easier said than
done
not a quick means to grow your muscle
however oh and one more that I forgot to
mention get outside in the Sun vitamin D
is great for testosterone building it
acts as a kind of master key for many of
your hormones and improves your sleep
and this is another one that I've
noticed personally getting more sunshine
more time outside does help to increase
my feelings of masculine with bitter
ability i rambled on there for a good
old while hopefully I've given you some
ideas about health testosterone works
whether or not certain products of Yee
and what some of the other means for
boosting testosterone ah if I was going
to just lay it out there how I would
recommend boosting testosterone I would
say get as much sleep as possible try to
avoid letting your blood sugar dip
especially if you're on a bulk eat more
saturated fats get outside as well and
sure maybe give some of those
testosterone boosting supplements a go
I'm trying ta a you might want to try
that one
but don't pin all your hopes on it it
may well turn out to be
waste of your cash so focus on the sleep
focus on the food and good luck boosting
that testosterone so thanks for watching
guys hope you found that interesting or
useful and didn't go on too much please
let me know what you think in the
comments below and I just want to
quickly show you my new home gym here
that I've been setting up I'll be making
some videos in this room soon in the
future I was actually going to do a
video on using this my parallel bars but
then I hurt my back which is why we got
testosterone boosting instead so stay
tuned for that again thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this please like share
and subscribe it helps me out a great
deal and check out my blog in the
comments below maybe follow me on
Twitter maybe on Instagram I don't know
maybe check me out on Facebook whatever
you want and I'll catch it in the next
one thanks so much for watching and bye
for now